.
FOR 25 YEARS AS AN ANCHOR AT FOX
I HAVE BEEN ACCUSTOMS TO
DEBATING ISSUES.
BUT SINCE THE PRESIDENT HIRED
HIS POSSE TO TAKE OVER
WASHINGTON, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GAS LIGHTING
AMERICA.
THEY WANT TO MAKE US BELIEVE
WHAT WE ARE SEEING AND
EXPERIENCING IS NOT HAPPENING AT
ALL.
>> 700 MIGRANTS GATHERING UNDER
A BRIDGE AFTER CROSSING THERE.
BORDER PATROL HAS STARTED
RELEASING MIGRANTS ON CITY
STREETS.
>> IT'S OPEN FOR YOU TO COME
ILLEGALLY, RIGHT?
>> ILLEGALLY.
THAT'S TRUE.
BRIAN: THIS IS REALITY AND THE
BORDER BIDEN STYLE.
>> WE HAVE A SECURE BORDER.
BRIAN: IT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
HIS REALITY SHOW HAS TEXAS
GOVERNOR ABBOTT DESPERATE BUSING
IMMIGRANTS INTO NEW YORK AND
CHICAGO TO SHOW YOU THE CRISIS
THEY ARE FACING IS REAL, EVEN
THOUGH THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
YOU SAY OUR ROAD TO FREEDOM AND
ENERGY IS GREEN ENERGY AND GREEN
TECHNOLOGY.
>> FOLKS, THE GREAT AMERICAN
ROAD TRIP WILL BE FULLY
ELECTRIFIED.
THE CHARGING STATION WILL BE UP
AND AS EASY TO FIND AS GAS
STATIONS ARE.
BRIAN: CHINA HAS THE BATTERY
COMPONENTS.
YOU SAY THE ECONOMY IS GREAT.
>> THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN, WE
HAVE AN ECONOMIC RESURGENCE.
BRIAN: YOU SAY AMERICANS ARE
LIVING BETTER.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE BETTER
OFF.
ALL PEOPLE.
BRIAN: YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT, EVEN
IF YOU YELL IT.
WHEN YOU TOOK OFFICE INFLATION
WAS 1%, IT'S NOW 8.3%.
YOU KEEP TELLING US YOU ARE A
UNIFIER.
BUT WHAT YOU ARE DOING AND
SAYING IS NOTHING OF THE SORT.
>> THIS IS NOT YOUR FATHER'S
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS DON'T JUST
THREATEN US PERSONALLY.
THEY REPRESENT EXTREMISM THAT
THREATENS THE VERY FOUNDATIONS
OF OUR REPUBLIC.
BRIAN: HE'S WILLING TO SAY
ANYTHING TO STEM THE RED WAVE.
MAYBE PERHAPS HE'S A SEINFELD
FAN.
>> JERRY, JUST REMEMBER, IT'S
NOT A LIE IF YOU BELIEVE IT.
BRIAN: OR YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THE
HEYDAY OF SNL.
>> MY NAME IS TOMMY AND I'M A
MEMBER OF PATHOLOGICAL LIARS
ANONYMOUS.
IN FACT I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THAT ORGANIZATION.
BRIAN: JOE, DO YOURSELF A FAVOR
AND THE NATION, TELL IS LIKE IT
IS, NOT THE WAY